em
[Música]
casa tomar chimarrão
ou será que estamos sozinhos no universo
como a vida surgiu no nosso planeta
bilhões de anos atrás como ela vem
evoluindo ao longo desse tempo para dar
origem a todas as formas de vida como
conhecemos hoje em dia em nosso planeta
Essas são perguntas que vemos nos
fazemos nos fazendo há milhares de anos
a civilização humana vem fazendo isso há
milhares de anos mas é somente nas
últimas décadas que nós temos de fato as
ferramentas científicas e tecnológicas
para tentar responder essas perguntas e
nesse contexto que o que vem sendo
desenvolvido uma ferramenta nova da
ciência conhecida como te como
astrobiologia e astrobiologia um campo
de pesquisa Inter multi e
transdisciplinar que tem o objetivo de
tentar entender o fenômeno da vida no
universo e eu venho me dedicando a essa
área já há 20 anos e venho mergulhando
muito a fundo no registro geológico do
nosso planeta desde a forma da a ação
bilhões de anos atrás até o surgimento
dos primeiros organismos vivos cerca de
3,7 bilhões de anos atrás isso é muito
tempo atrás e nesse período os
organismos que surgiram eram muito
simples organismos unicelulares
parecidos com as bactérias ou com as
cianobactérias como conhecemos hoje em
dia ou seja são organismos muito simples
minúsculos tamanho micrométrico que
realmente é são diferentes dos que a
gente encontra hoje em dia esses
organismos ele se diversificaram e se
espalharam pelo nosso planeta povoando
praticamente todos os nichos que
conhecemos do fundo dos oceanos até o
Alto das montanhas e eles ficaram
dominantes por bilhões de anos no nosso
planeta até que cerca de 600 milhões de
anos atrás aconteceu um evento muito
importante conhecido como A Explosão do
cambriano nesse período e é aconteceu há
uma diversificação da vida incrível
daquelas formas de vida simples
unicelulares que existiam aconteceu a
surgiram todas as formas como conhecemos
em especial os primeiros animais como
como conhecemos um desses animais que
surgiu aqui no nosso próprio no nosso
próprio país é chamado corumbé lavenére
essa cor um Bela é uma espécie de uma
medusa um organismo que vivia no fundo
do mar preso preso no substrato e ele
tinha uma inovação fantástica da da
ecologia ele tinha uma carapaça rígida
ou seja ele tem uma parte dura do corpo
que servia para protegê-lo do ataque de
outros organismos Esse foi uma inovação
que mudou completamente como os animais
se relacionavam naquela época mas mesmo
assim o planeta ele continua sendo um
planeta de bactérias grande parte da
biomassa da terra cerca de
dois terços de toda a biomassa do nosso
planeta é feita de microorganismos o que
nós eu mesmo aqui no meu corpo tenho
mais células bacterianas do que células
humanas e são essas células que fazem a
diferença para a evolução da vida no
nosso próprio planeta e elas existem
elas estão presentes desde o fundo dos
oceanos até realmente o Alto das
montanhas estão presentes em todos os
ambientes como conhecemos em especial os
ambientes mais extremos que existem como
os ambientes muito quentes os ambientes
muito frios os ambientes salgado os
ambientes com baixa quantidade de água
os ambientes com alta radiação e alta
pressão e os organismos que vivem nesses
ambientes especial os microrganismos que
vivem nesses ambientes são conhecidos
como extremófilos eles são extremamente
importantes como é que faz essa pergunta
sobre a evolução da vida EA
possibilidade de vida em outros planetas
porque eles são modelos do que a gente
pode procurar por vida fora da terra e a
gente tem que se perguntar então onde
será que eu posso procurar por esse tipo
de vida será que vale a pena procurar na
nossa vizinhança cósmica
e o nosso Fedora ou será que vale a pena
ir muito mais distante para além do
sistema solar no chamados exoplanetas
vamos falar primeiro do Sistema Solar
quando a gente fala do sistema solar as
distâncias Elas são grandes Mas não tão
grandes assim a gente consegue com os
nossos foguetes chegar na lua em alguns
dias chegar em uma arte em alguns meses
chegaram nos Planetas mais distantes em
alguns meses vários meses ou anos então
não é tão impossível da gente enviar
foguetes e robôs e talvez em alguns
casos até humanos para esses ambientes e
a gente vem explorando diferentes locais
do sistema solar o primeiro local é Mark
eu tô aqui no palco todo vermelho então
tô bem ambientado e marcha interessante
porque no passado Marte teve condições
muito parecidas com as da terra teve
água líquida na sua superfície uma
atmosfera espessa é oceanos rios lagos
chuvas e fontes de energia tudo que a
gente entende que a vida precisa para
existir para prosperar e para ter
surgido então a gente é realmente que a
vida pode ter surgido em marcha no
passado mais com o passar do tempo Marte
perdeu o seu campo magnético que protege
como um escudo o planeta da radiação
solar sem esse Escudo a radiação
destruiu a atmosfera do planeta e a água
todas evaporou marca acabou se tornando
um deserto frio e gelado e seco muito
seco mas a gente entende que a gente
pode procurar por organismos vivos
pretéritos por fósseis naquele planeta
para isso a gente tem enviados ondas
muito avançadas como atuar o som da
percebe que está no planeta vasculhando
por esses sinais de vida a chamadas
bioassinaturas que são quaisquer
indícios da atividade da vida ali no
planeta mesmo da atividade há bilhões de
anos a traz inclusive ela está coletando
amostras para trazê-las de volta para
terra em uma futura missão espacial
então isso vem acontecendo aqui pertinho
da gente em breve a gente vai ter
amostras frescas de Marte para levar
para o acelerador de partículas no seu a
estudar elas em detalhes Mas além disso
a gente tem ido além e pensado além de
Marte além de marcha a gente pode falar
da lua de lua de Júpiter conhecida como
Europa Europa é uma lua muito
interessante porque debaixo de uma
crosta de gelo de dezena de quilômetros
de espessura existe todo um oceano
líquido muito profundo com cerca de 100
Km de profundidade tem mais água ali do
que existe na terra se você quiser se
vocês lembram que a terra que conhecida
como Planeta Azul Gagarin disso né disse
que a Terra era azul imagina a Europa
muito mais azul que a terra e debaixo
desse oceano líquido existem Fontes
hidrotermais Submarinas verdadeiros
vulcões despejando elementos químicos e
energia nesses oceanos tudo que a vida
precisa para ter surgido e para existir
então gente acredita que Europa seja um
grande potencial para gente procurar por
vida aqui no nosso sistema solar
e em breve a gente vai mandar sondas
para lá com a sonda Europa clipper da
Nasa aqui nos anos 2000 e 30 deve
vasculhar o planeta procurando pelas
mesmas bioassinaturas que é percebe mas
tá procurando o macho bom E além disso O
que existe além do nosso Cosmo sempre
sai do nosso sistema solar a gente vai
encontrar os chamados exoplanetas
exoplaneta é todo o planeta que orbitam
uma estrela que não seja o sol existem
centenas de bilhões de estrelas na nossa
galáxia e o que a gente tem aprendido
nos últimos anos é que praticamente
todas as estrelas que você observa no
firmamento todas as estrelas da galáxia
e talvez do universo estejam
acompanhadas de planetas ao seu redor e
alguns desses planetas eles estão na
posição certa da estrela nem muito perto
para não ser muito quente nem muito
longe para não ser muito frio de maneira
que a temperatura no planeta seja
adequada para que exista água líquida na
superfície e talvez para que ele seja
habitável E esses são chamados mundos a
a 100 milhões desses mundos por aí a
fora por isso que vale a pena procurar
inclusive aqui pertinho de nós a 4,2
anos-luz de distância da Terra existe um
planeta chamado próxima B que orbitam a
estrela próxima Centauro que é uma
estrela anã vermelha da constelação de
Centauro pertinho da terra 4,2 anos-luz
mas tão pertinho assim 4,2 anos-luz quer
dizer que a luz demora 4,2 anos para
chegar 4,2 anos para voltar são cerca de
40 trilhões de quilômetros de distância
mesmo com o nosso foguete mais moderno e
mais avançada antes demoraria cerca de
100 mil anos para chegar nesse planeta
por isso não dá para pensar em estudar
esse planeta nem humanos nem com robôs a
gente precisa usar técnicas astronômicas
picolé tem a luz ou sinais de rádio
usando grandes radiotelescópios ou
grandes telescópios aqui em terra ou no
espaço para vasculhar e procurar por
indícios de atividade biológica desse
planeta mas que tipo de atividade o que
a gente deve procurar bom é difícil mas
microrganismos podem alterar um planeta
em escala Global se vocês pensarem aqui
na terra mesmo esse oxigênio que eu tô
respirando agora ele é fruto da
atividade microbiana são cianobactérias
que estão produzindo esse oxigênio nos
oceanos há bilhões de anos e ele vem se
acumulando na atmosfera são sinais como
esses sinais da presença de elementos
químicos de moléculas na atmosfera dos
planetas que a gente deve procurar
usando esses grandes telescópios e para
isso a gente precisa fazer como Darwin
fez é centenas de anos atrás sair pelo
nosso planeta vasculhando a
biodiversidade e entendendo como os
organismos funcionam para a partir daí
fazer um grande conclusão de como eles
podem produzir e o que eles podem
produzir em termos de Bill assinaturas
para isso os modernos às pro biólogos
têm usado as ferramentas da
microbiologia ambiental e da biologia
molecular para vasculhar toda a
diversidade de seres vivos que existem
no nosso planeta os menores e mais
simples bactérias ou cianobactérias o
Arqueiro as metanogênicas no fundo do
oceano enfim toda a diversidade de vida
que existe no planeta e tentar fazer
essa Since para entender como que elas
podem funcionar bom mas não é só e em
especial os organismos extremófilos são
muito importantes nesse contexto porque
eles podem servir de base como eu falei
para procurar por vida fora da terra por
eles serem excelentes modelos desses
ambientes bom onde a gente deve procurar
esses organismos extremófilos existem
vários ambientes aqui na terra que são
extremos e são análogos a ambientes
espaciais esses ambientes análogos são
vários um exemplo deles é é Antártica
Antártica ao Polo Sul é um deserto frio
seco com alta incidência de radiação
baixíssima quantidade de nutrientes
disponível e nós vimos estudando esse
esse ambiente já há décadas mas o Brasil
Inclusive tem uma base na Antártica para
quem não conhece financiar a Ciência
Tecnologia e inovação e a gente vem
estudando esse ambiente no seu gelo os
seus oceanos o seu solo as suas rochas a
fauna todos os organismos que existem os
astrobiólogo vem explorando isso nos
últimos anos para tentar entender quais
organismos ali poderiam viver por
exemplo e mate ou em Europa além da
Antártica existem lugares interessantes
aqui na América Latina também por
exemplo Deserto do Atacama Deserto do
Atacama que fica no Chile é um deserto
extremamente frio e seco existem locais
onde não onde não chove não leva a
centenas de anos existem os salários
também são regiões com alta concentração
de sal Grandes Lagos alunos que são
muito parecidos aos Lagos salobros
encontrados em Marte regiões de altitude
o Deserto do Atacama encontra o
Cordilheira dos Andes subindo até cerca
de seis mil metros de altitude com alta
incidência de radiação e outros e outros
ambientes super interessantes que podem
ser explorados no de é mas não é só de
ambientes fora do Brasil que a gente
precisa viver aqui no Brasil existem
ambientes análogos também interessantes
a gente pode por exemplo e na região de
Araruama no Rio de Janeiro Ontem todo
mundo gosta de passar o feriado fim de
semana fazer um lanchinho vão lá existem
Salinas e nessa Salinas se desenvolve
micro-organismos muito especiais
micro-organismos que me chama
halofilicos que gostam do sal e eles
constituem tapetes microbianos
gigantescos que são muito parecidos com
que existir na vida aqui na Terra
Bilhões de anos atrás talvez a terra
fosse como é Araruama hoje em dia e
talvez Marte também seja assim então
esse tipo de ambiente a gente vem
explorando o ambiente análogo aqui no
Brasil e outros também por exemplo a
região Histórica de Diamantina em Minas
Gerais que é interessante por si só pelo
seu valor histórico mas também é uma
região ferrífera altíssimas
concentrações de ferro no solo permitem
que a gente explore os microrganismos
que vivem ali nas cavernas no Sul e nas
rochas e entender como eles poderiam
viver em Marte da mesma forma graças à
alta concentração de ferro que existe no
planeta vermelho que é vermelho
exatamente pelo ferro oxidado que existe
na superfície e não só o System os
manguezais na em toda a costa brasileira
que onde as regiões as condições anox
secas os aproximam ambiente sem oxigênio
no sistema solar existem a caatinga que
é um deserto quente e seco no norte
nordeste do Brasil também com baixíssimo
aporte de nutrientes em alguns casos com
alta concentração de metais pesados em
existem vários ambientes que a gente vem
explorando e toda essa diversidade ela
pode ser importante porque a gente pode
aplicar ela agora para problemas bem
concretos para novos problemas e novos
desafios que estão sendo criados e
construídos nesse momento nós estamos
vivendo na época do New Space a nova
exploração espacial nessa nova
exploração espacial a gente não tem não
só as grandes
e internacionais participando mas também
empresas privadas como abrir word in
Virgin galactic's spaceshiptwo que estão
desenvolvendo
mecanismos foguetes e naves espaciais
para colocar humanos em órbita na lua e
talvez até mesmo em Marte com a promessa
de ficarmos estabelecemos Uma colônia em
Marte de longa duração eu isso tá
acontecendo nesse exato momento mais
grandes desafios surgem quando a gente
coloca essa proposta de viver no espaço
Por grandes períodos de tempo em
especial a biotecnologia pode ajudar
agência desenvolver e resolver esses
problemas a gente precisa por exemplo
produzir biomassa para ser usada como
alimento ao longo de todo esse tempo a
gente precisa produzir vitaminas para os
astronautas a gente precisa reciclar o
oxigênio EA água da a água das estações
espaciais a gente precisa produzir os
bioplásticos que vão ser usado para
fazer construções e a radiação ou enfim
produzir qualquer material que a gente
precisa no espaço e todos esses desafios
podem ser enfrentados de fato com a
biotecnologia em especial usando a
biotecnologia derivada dos organismos
extremófilos encontrados aqui no nosso
próprio planeta então quando a gente
pensa o quando a gente vê uma cena do
filme Perdido em Marte Por exemplo
quando Marco volto aí tá lá plantando
batatas para produzir seu alimento eu
quando vejo isso eu penso Poxa Talvez
daqui a alguns anos a gente não esteja
plantando batatas em Marte mas a gente
provavelmente vai estar cultivando
cianobactérias do Deserto do Atacama
talvez a gente esteja reciclando o
oxigênio usando Alô bactérias lá das
Salinas do Rio de Janeiro e talvez a
gente esteja produzindo uma boa
cervejinha Marciana usando as leveduras
que eu coletei lá dos Andes então todas
as todas essas tecnologias elas podem
ser desenvolvidas graças ao conhecimento
da biodiversidade do nosso próprio
planeta e e o conhecimento da vida aqui
na terra bem cal cada o nosso chão quer
o quê astrobiologia faz permite que a
gente Entenda como a vida funcione desde
os seus menores organismos até os mais
complexos e talvez com isso desenvolver
a metodologia para a gente é produzir o
entender as bioassinaturas que vale a
pena a gente procurar em outros planetas
e de forma final talvez responder à
pergunta se estamos de fato sozinhos no
universo além disso a biotecnologia que
vem de todo esse desenvolvimento pode
nos permitir resolver os grandes
desafios tecnológicos necessários para
gente estabelecer colônias em Marte e na
lua ou talvez até sair do sistema solar
e nos tornarmos uma espécie realmente
multiplanar etária e talvez é impossível
de ser extinta Quem sabe né E talvez
assim a gente possa de fato deixar o
nosso berço cósmico algum dia o nosso
planeta é alçar voos e eu realizar o meu
sonho de infância D só falta obrigado
[Aplausos]
E aí